Alte Daten, ich will sie nicht mehr sehen, alte Daten, na na na na na, USB-Stick, das erste Mal klopzt nicht, drehen um, da geht dir sicher rein, Drucker Treiber, so nirgend dem geht es nicht weiter, Druckertreiber. Und was ihr gerade gehört habt, war alte Daten von The The, der neue Smash-It, heute bei uns im Studio. Ich heisse das Projekt. Ein wenig negativ angetaucht natürlich, ihr kennt das, Kritiker in Herz und Blut, Stefan. Stefan Michael Tietze. Und gegenüber von mir sitzt Flo und die David Pascal Will. Der macht sonst gute Sachen, du hast dich da voran mit deinem Projekt The The, deine Band The The. Ich sag Cut The The. Okay, komplette Leerzeichen. Leer einfach Space. Das macht aber sämtliche Datenverarbeitungsprogramme kaputt, wenn du einfach ein Leerzeichen hast. Das ist immer irgendein Problem, weil es einfach nicht registriert ist. Ja, ich glaube, es würde euch zututun, zuträglich sein, wenn komplett ganz alle Datenmaterialien einfach weg sind. Und es ist natürlich auch eine Botschaft, wir machen die Daten kaputt, die Daten sind eh alt, die Idee von dem Song Alte Daten ist ja ohnehin, das Daten Big Data ist vorbei, Big Data, sagen wir quasi, also es geht wieder ums Leben, es geht wieder ums Unbenennbare, es geht wieder ums Unzählbare, um die Liebe, um die Emotionen und Daten sind vergessen. Ich höre dich schon seit einer Minute nicht mehr zu. Tut vielleicht auch Malte nicht, der hat uns diesen herrlichen Zusammenschnitt geschickt. Man könnte also auch sagen, alte Malte Daten, könnte man auch sagen. Ja, kann man alles machen. Malte, vielen Dank, du hast eine Mail bekommen.
Da geht schon direkt los.
Oder habe ich eine Mail bekommen? Ich habe auch eine Mail bekommen.
Das kann auch ich gewesen sein.
Ich bin wieder ein bisschen
auf Facebook aktiv, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ich habe ein bisschen auf Facebook
gestalkt. Einen Schritt nach vorne, drei zurück.
Das ist wirklich.
Aber ich glaube, Facebook merkt,
wenn man da aktiv ist. Das ist wie so ein Stein, wo man den hochhebt und dann ganz viele Spinnen plötzlich rauskommen. Und wenn du einmal nur auf Facebook bist, kriegst du den nächsten Tag jeden Tag eine Mail, Rebecca Schwarz hat was gepostet und du denkst, allein die Neugier, wer zur Hölle könnte Facebook denken, dass mich das interessiert, dass man sich das dann anguckt und dann ist man wieder drin. Ja, es ist so ein bisschen wie manchmal so, man hat Augenkontakt, zu viel Augenkontakt im Club. Also so im Internet ist so, wenn man zu lange auf einer Seite war, dann kriegt man so eine Mail so, hey, hi. Hi, du, ich habe gemerkt, du bist auch da. Ja, genau. Cookies sind eigentlich der Augenkontakt der Internetwelt in gewisser Weise. Ja, genau. Und dann war ich so, war ich ein bisschen zu lange wieder auf die Zeit. Fehler. Und dann plötzlich krieg ich mal so eine Mail. Ah, Sie lesen uns. Wie wär's denn mit dem Angebot? Als würden die nur darauf warten, dass einer mal so im Kiosk aus Versehen, so natürlich zwischen Playboy und Schlüsselloch, mal irgendwie über die Zeit geht und dann sofort Ah, wollen Sie die kaufen? Ah ja, wollen Sie das? Ich lese es les Ihnen die Trinke vor. Ja, Jahresausgaben, brrrr, zack, direkt drauf.
Ähm, das stimmt schon, aber ich wollte jetzt nicht zu derespektivisch sein, ich mag dein, ich bin nicht, ich mag dein Bandprojekt, ich bin jetzt kein Riesenfan.
Du, wir leben von Negativität, wir leben von der Abneigung anderer Menschen und damit befeuerst du unser Projekt jeden Tag.
Ich möchte nur sagen, Malte hat einen fantastischen Job gemacht.
Malte hat das gut gemacht, ja.
Also aus diesen Fetzen, diesen Demo-Fetzen, die du uns angeboten hast. Alte Daten. Genau, das war das ungefähr.
Die sind schon ganz schön alt, alte Daten. Und dann an der Linkenstelle, la la la la, hat Malte wirklich das
absolute Beste rausgeholt, das ist grosser Scale, grosser Scale, ich freue mich mehr von Malte zu hören.
Vor allem, es ist ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn die dritte Liedzeile schon, na na na na, so klar, jedesied hat mal so einen Hänger, ne, also die meisten Lieder haben so ein la la la la, aber halt irgendwo gegen das letzte Drittel, wo man sagt, gut, fuck it, das schreiben wir noch im Studio fertig und dann macht man es doch nicht, Kaffee zu spät, irgendwie, dann nimmt man irgendwas auf. Und dann so ein genialer Moment, wo jemand sagt, wie wär's, wenn es einfach la la la bleibt? Ja. Scha la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la. Ja, das war unsere Demo-Idee. Nee, es bleibt einfach beim la la la. Es bleibt immer schon beim ersten Entwurf so. Egal, was man macht, es bleibt am Ende immer so. Genau wie bei der Folge. Wir sagen auch immer, lass uns dreimal drei aufnehmen und wir schneiden die besten Sachen zusammen und so. Und am Ende sagen wir nach der ersten Folge, ich habe so viel Brezel noch im Rucksack, wenn ich jetzt nicht anfange die zu essen, dann werde ich heute nicht fertig. So viel Brezel noch in den Backenzähnen. Ja, ich muss Dinge essen. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich, Katjana hat mal erzählt, dass sie in den USA bei so Overeater, unsere liebste Freundin Katjana Gerz. Okay, du machst direkt eine Reihenfolge rein. Nimm das, Joyce Ilk, nimm das, fucking Thais, viertliebst, zweitliebst, nimm das alles, alle Frauen, die wir kennen. Rebecca Schwarz, die auf Facebook lauert.
What the fuck will ich, mit der du es reconnected hast, aber trotzdem unsere liebste Freundin Katjana geht auf der Eins.
Ja, die hat ja mal gesagt, sie war in den USA bei den Overeater Anonymous und einfach nur um zu sehen, was da los ist und so. Sie hatte selber das Problem nicht, aber dieses Konzept Overeater.
Wie viel musst du overeaten, um wirklich Anonymous durch die Strassen zu laufen? Das ist die Frage, ich finde auch interessant, dass es für alles nochmal was Anonymes gibt.
Also es gibt ja die anonymen Alkoholiker, aber die anonymen Spielsüchtigen, die anonymen Hochsüchtigen, die immer hoch wollen auf dem Baum oder was auch immer, das schränkt natürlich das Leben auch stark ein. Alles gibt es nochmal anonym. So, ich finde das interessant. Und ich glaube, dieses Overeater passt zu mir. So, ich muss alles essen, was da ist. Es ist so, alles, was da ist, muss ich aufessen. Und ich glaube, das geht schon in dieses O-Eater rein. Ich glaube, es ist Anonymous disziplinlos. Ja, oder halt Anonymous Fettsack, glaube ich, kann man auch einfach letzten Endes sagen. Also ist Over-Eater nicht eine Umschreibung für erhöhtes Körpergewicht? Ich glaube, es ist eine Mindset-Sache. Deswegen habe ich mich am Anonym gestossen. Er zeigt auf seinen Kopf hinten. Das Mindset ist hinten im Hinterkopf? Ich hab, na gut, merkt man, dass ich Neurochirurg bin? Du hast doch einen Vogel, oder? Zeigt auf die genaue Schädestelle. Wo nachgewiesenerweise das bescheuerte Hirnareal liegt. Ich muss noch mal ein bisschen nachdenken, so, die können immer, normalerweise ist die Schläfe hier, stellvertretend fürs Gehirn, Pars pro toto quasi, man tippt sich auf die Schläfe, aber wenn du Neurochirurg bist, wie ich, ja gut, ich hab das mal gelernt, nebenbei, gekellnert, nebenbei Neurochirurg gelernt und dann weisst du genau, wo Dinge im Kopf sind. Aber ich gebe dir mal ein Beispiel für die Logik, weil Overeaten ist eine Logik-Sache. Und zwar, also stell dir vor, ein altes Beispiel, ich lebe bei meiner Eltern. Meine Mutter kocht zum Mittag Spaghetti. So einen grossen Topf.
Ja, zum Topf.
Wir alle essen Spaghetti, aber es bleibt noch was übrig.
Im Topf.
Im Topf. Jetzt gehe ich, sagen wir mal, in die Stadt und bin in der Stadt unterwegs.
Sagen wir mal.
Und mache da Sachen in der Stadt.
Ja.
Und jetzt weiß ich aber nicht, wenn ich nach Hause komme, ist da noch was von diesem Spaghetti übrig? Weiß ich nicht. Weiss man nicht. Ich bin ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr esse nichts und muss dann aber spekulieren, ob zu Hause noch was übrig ist. Dann überlege ich mir, sind wir mal ehrlich, und das ist auch Teil dieser Suchtlogik, dass du denkst, ich werde ohnehin, wenn ich nach Hause komme und es ist da, werde ich es essen. Egal, ob ich jetzt schon was esse oder nicht. Also es wird am Ende gegessen werden. Eher wie John Mulaney über seine Kokssucht spricht. Es ist ähnlich, weil er irgendwann an einem Punkt war, wo er gesagt hat, immer wenn er seine Hände an Kokain bekommen sind, dann ist seine Logik gewesen, die mitnehmen. Es wäre übrigens im praktischen Sinne mein Vorschlag beim Handyladen, immer wenn ihr eine Steckdose in der Nähe habt, schliesst es einfach mal an. Was soll schief gehen? Im schlimmsten Fall habt ihr mehr Strom und kommt gut durch den Tag. Ja, es ist ja nicht schwerer dadurch. Ihr verbraucht auch nicht mehr Energie, nur weil ihr das an der Steckdose habt. Aber ich glaube, das ist ganz wichtig in dieser Suchtlogik, dieses, ich kenne mich so gut, ich muss gar keine Entscheidung treffen, weil ich weiss, ich werde es eh so. Jetzt geht es aber weiter. Das heisst, ich bin in der Stadt und ich weiss, ich werde zu Hause, wenn ich da ankomme, eh was essen, also kann ich ja jetzt was essen in der Stadt. Also gehe ich in der Stadt irgendwo was essen. Dann fahre ich nach Hause, habe schon drin, naja, wenn das Essen da ist, dann esse ich es auch. Aber es geht bei dir nie im Hunger. Ne, ne, das ist egal. Es geht nur darum, ist das Essen noch da, kann ich das essen. Ich finde nicht, dass man da, wir überspringen, wir kommen gleich drauf zurück. Und jetzt komme ich zu Hause an und sehe, die Spacketti sind weg. Aber, weil ich in meinem Kopf ja diese Mahlzeit schon eingeplant habe. Die du nicht mehr brauchst. Die ich natürlich nicht brauche, denke ich mir, ah, jetzt kann ich ja noch was essen, weil jetzt ist diese Mahlzeit ja quasi offen, erlaubt, also mache ich mir dann noch was zu essen zu Hause, obwohl ich das halt gar nicht hätte machen müssen. Es ist so diese Logik, dass du startest jeden Tag und du hast Mahlzeiten, die erlaubt sind. Es geht nicht um Hunger, es geht um Mahlzeiten, die erlaubt sind und dann kannst du die sozusagen abarbeiten und wenn was erlaubt ist und dann aber doch gar nicht stattfinden muss, musst du es trotzdem essen, einfach weil es erlaubt ist. Das ist glaube ich so die Lösung. Es ist ja auch spannend, wenn man aus dem Heimkorrektiv herauskommt. Deine erste eigene Wohnung oder WG. Schön München, Mosach, Pommbox, ganz viele Pommboxen. Naja, du hast zu Hause ein Korrektiv. Mutter, Geschwister, die dir sagen, Alter, du hast doch gerade erst gegessen, eine Mutter, die dir sagt, nein, wir essen gleich später Abendessen, du isst dir jetzt nicht noch eine Packung Kaiserschmarrn aus der Packung, die du nicht mal zu Kaiserschmarrn verarbeitest. Den Kaiserschmarrn to go, an der Kasse, den man halt noch so in den Wagen mit reinwirft. Du kippst jetzt nicht so Pancake-Kram in den Mund, sondern wir essen später zu Abend und so lange kannst du noch warten.
Dieses Korrektiv bricht ja weg. Als erwachsener Mensch, du bist 18, 19, siehst aus nach München in deiner erste eigene Wohnung. Was war da los? Dann geht's los. Pommboxen, viele Pommboxen. Ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist. Das ist Döner ohne Brot in einer Box mit Pommes. Pommdöner. Pommbox. Pommdönerbox. Ich kenne das, gut, in Bayern sagt man Pommbox, das ist ja Pommbox. So, das ist jetzt bayerischer traditioneller Dialekt. Und ein bayerisches traditionelles Gericht. Richtig, genau. Und davon ganz viele, weil du natürlich auch einfach nachts sagen kannst, ich hole mir noch was. Und dann ist natürlich auch so diese Anlasspsychologie, weil du weißt eigentlich ja sehr gut, wie viele Kalorien alles hat, du weißt sehr gut, wie viel du essen kannst, weil du dich damit ja beschäftigst, weil du immer überlegst, wie viel Platz habe ich noch heute, aber dann gibt es ja immer Anlässe und da ist man unglaublich kreativ darin, Anlässe zu finden. Ich glaube, da habe ich auch mal so eine Alkoholiker-Doku gesehen, wo das ähnlich ist, wo du ständig was zu feiern hast und dann trinkt man halt so ein bisschen was und so ist es auch und du kannst alles immer zu einem Anlass hindrehen. Also du hattest heute einen besonders guten Tag, dann darfst du dich belohnen. Du hattest heute einen besonders schlechten Tag, dann eben als Trost kannst du sozusagen noch was holen. Ich glaube auch bei mir, Sport und das hebt sich auf und Ernährung. Also ich mache ja Sport, um besser auszusehen, eine bessere Figur zu haben. Gesundheit spielt ja gar keine Rolle. so und dann, ich esse aber, seitdem ich Sport mache, natürlich viel ungesünder, weil ich immer mir sozusagen das frei kaufe. Ich kaufe mir, und auf eine Art stimmt es ja auch, ich kaufe mir Kalorien frei. Jetzt würde ich behaupten, wahrscheinlich jetzt sowieso 80 % Ernährung, 20 % Sport, das heißt, diese Rechnung geht sowieso schon nicht so ganz auf. Ich gehe eine Stunde irgendwie ins Fitnessstudio und sage dann, oh, dann habe ich mir heute Abend McDonalds verdient und esse auch nur noch Quatsch. Und das ist ja, es ist eine Abbeizspirale.
Es ist eigentlich, der Versuch es besser zu machen macht es schlimmer. Ich habe irgendwann auch angefangen, möglichst gesundes Frühstück zu machen, so Smoothie mit wirklich allem Samen und Gedöns und Flocken und Schalenflocken und geraspelten Flöhen und Maden und wirklich allem.
Mega, klingt fantastisch. Alles, was ich irgendwann mal gelesen habe auf Instagram reingepackt und das war mein Untergang. Weil ab dem Moment startest du den Tag mit, ich bin ja im Bonus, ich habe ja Plus gemacht, weil ich habe jetzt ein gesundes Frühstück gegessen. Und den Rest des Tages denkst du dir bei jeder Gelegenheit, ich kann mir noch zwei Bountys reintun, ah noch drei Fritt, ah hier, ich habe ein gutes Frühstück gehabt. Bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno,
und das spielt den ganzen Tag im Malmkopf.
Bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno,
bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, Giotto, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, Giotto, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, jelly, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, Giotto. Und mit diesem Lies gehe ich auch den durch den Tag. Und am Ende ist natürlich unterm Strich starkes Minus oder starkes Plus an Kalorien, weil es hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt und es ist auch noch ein schlecht schmeckendes Frühstück. Also du hast worst of hers worse, worst of hers worse, bist du komplett unten durch. Wie dein Kopf dich austricksen kann einfach. Ja, es ist wirklich eine klassische Sucht, weil bist du fresssüchtig. Ja, ich glaube, das ist dieses Over-Eaten so, aber das ist natürlich... Naja, bei mir ist es wirklich so, habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal erzählt, aber sobald ich im Supermarkt war, einkaufen war, so Süssigkeiten für die Woche besorgt habe, sind die alle am gleichen Abend noch weg. Und da fange ich dann wirklich an, mir Sorgen zu machen. Also auch so, was ich gerade sehr mag, ist diese ungarische Salami. Die gibt es eigentlich in jedem Supermarkt. Man verbindet Ungarn gar nicht notwendigerweise mit Salam. Finde ich nämlich auch nicht, deswegen ist die so eingebrannt bei mir.
Aber diese Ungare, die ist so ein bisschen herber, die ist so sehr würzig, die ist so ein bisschen, das ist so, im besten Sinne hat man danach so ein bisschen so einen trockenen Mund.
Die ist so richtig einnehmend vollmundig, würzig. Ich liebe die, die ist so klein und dick.
Und die esse ich gerade gern. Und in der Woche esse ich esse ich da so eine von denke ich dann hole ich mir zwei beim supermarkt und dann kann es will nicht sein dass ich an dem abend die ganze salami esse und das kann beilagen oder ist es wirklich ein reiner salami genuss zwischendurch haben wir immer mal mal wieder so ein Stückchen, aber unverhältnismässig. Und wenn du dann kein Korrektiv hast, also von mir selber, kennt man ja, man hat inneren Monolog, innere Gedanken, man baut sich die Welt zurecht, alles stimmt schon. Bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, bueno, ich würde das auch niemals in Gesellschaft machen. Das denke ich mir auch. Nee, nee, nee, das nicht. In Gesellschaft würde ich nicht diesen Salamikonsum gutheissen. Wenn ich das aber Leuten erzähle, dann sagen die, geht's noch? Ja, ja, die Reaktion kenne ich sehr gut. Ich habe auch grosse Angst, ich bin jetzt raus aus Köln, ich bin kein Kölner mehr, Kölner Jung, du hast einen Jung verloren. Deswegen sind wir jetzt hier in dieser tollen Abstellkammer. Richtig, und deswegen, ich überlege, es gibt auch Planungen, ob man vielleicht nochmal umzieht oder so, und da ist immer meine Angst, irgendwo zu wohnen, wo nicht direkt ein Supermarkt in der Nähe ist. Weil wenn ein Supermarkt in der Nähe ist, kann ich jeden Tag einkaufen und kann jeden Tag sagen, ein Kinderriegel. So, das kann ich beherrschen. Indem ich mal in einem Setting lebe, in dem man so einen Wocheneinkauf macht. Ende. Einfach Ende. Aus. Abgesetzt. Florentin will abgesetzt. Weil dieser Wocheneinkauf mit, naja, mal eine Packung Country, eine Packung Bueno, eine Packung Bueno, eine Packung Giotto und dann halt für die Woche alles am selben Abend weg. Ich finde gut, dass meine Süßigkeitenvorliebe inzwischen auch deine Süßigkeitenvorliebe ist. Bei dir ist es immer sehr Haselnelnusslastig. Was sehr spannend ist, weil ich hasse Haselnüsse. Ich mag Haselnüsse nicht, also unverarbeitet. Ja, aber gut, aber du magst, dass sie dominiert und zerstampft werden. Du magst es, das Blut deines Gegners zu schlürfen. Rein als Haselnuss, als Nuss? Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Würdelos. Würdelos zerkleinert. Ja, aber so zerstampft, zermahlen ist wieder gut, aber davor habe ich eher grosse Angst, das heisst, Eichhörnchen sind für dich eher ein Freund, weil die die Nüsse entsorgen, die besorgen, vergessen, das ist immer sehr süss, aber Moment, habe ich jetzt gerade richtig verstanden, du willst umziehen, willst du aus der Stadt raus, willst du aus der Stadt raus, ich bin nicht mehr so der Stadttyp, ich auchp. Ich auch nicht. Ich war früher kosmopolit, ich war in der Stadt, ich habe das brummende Leben gebraucht, das Kulturangebot, wirklich die rauschenden Feste, wirklich die brummenden Aktionen. Du bist ja immer einer, der noch sehr lange da war, der lange ausgeht und du schließt ja den Laden immer noch ab. Ja, ja, ja. Mir geht's aber ganz ähnlich. Zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben setzt dieser
altersmilde Gedanke ein. Und wir sind offiziell
langweilig, ab jetzt, glaube ich. Also das
ist, glaube ich, die Folge, wo man wirklich schreiben kann,
ab jetzt langweilig, so.
Ja, aber Kulturangebote hast du ja wie
nie zuvor in der Geschichte, jetzt auch auf dem Land.
Ja. Du kannst ja auf alle Filme zugreifen,
auf alle Bücher zugreifen.
Ich bin inzwischen auch, ich denke mir so ein
Häuschen im Wald. Wie läuft's eigentlich mit deinem Gewinnspiel? Ja, nochmal vielen Dank an alle Leute, die es dann bei Reddit gepostet haben, gefunden haben. Ich wollte es ja wirklich anonymisiert durchgeben, natürlich hat es nicht geklappt. Ich habe das, du sagst auch viel über meine Anonymisier-Skills aus, ich habe ja anonymisiert gesagt, bei welchem Gewinnspiel ich mitgemacht habe, habe nicht gesagt, worum es geht genau.
Du bist nicht bei den anonymen Gewinnspielern, du bist bei den offensichtlichen Gewinnspielern.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, es ging um ein Haus. Jedenfalls habe ich das so clever um die Ecke umschrieben, dass das Gewinnspiel diesen Ausschnitt unseres Podcasts als Werbung genommen hat für sich. Also das muss man auch mal sagen, ja. Die haben das bei Instagram diesen Ausschnitt genommen, wenn ich darüber spreche. Ach verdammt. Oder so, ah Stefan empfiehlt uns oder sowas. Wo ich dachte so, das war das Gegenteil. Ja, ja, ich hab's im Reddit auch gesehen, weil du hast ja versucht, es so zu formulieren, weil es gibt ja nur ein Haus. Das heißt, je mehr Leute teilnehmen, desto weniger geringer ist die Chance, dass jeder einzelne es gewinnen kann. Nicht nur das, jeder kann unendlich viele Lose kaufen und jedes Los, also es wird ein Los gezogen am Ende unter Aufsicht eines Notars, weil ich mir denke, das ist der Job, den ich will. Ein Notar, der neben einem Laptop sitzt, dafür kriegt er 10.000 Dollar. Ja, ja, einfach nur als du bist unbestechbar. Und jeder kann sich sehr viele Lose kaufen. Ich habe, glaube ich, ein so ein Los-Paket gekauft mit 15 Losen, was auch immer. Und hat dann natürlich gedacht, ah krass, ich bin der Einzige, der das kennt, ich gewinne dieses Haus. Ich habe 15 Lose. Ja, wie viele Leute nehmen da teil, 13? Ja, eben. Krass, ich habe alle Lose. Lose sind endlich. Inzwischen haben, glaube ich, so viele Leute mitgemacht und so so und was mich, also manchmal, ich bin manchmal so ein bisschen esoterisch, dass ich denke, wenn man sich Dinge extrem gut vorstellt, manifestieren, manifestieren, dann werden die Wahrheit, also wie zum Beispiel, manchmal habe ich so eine Vorahnung, das könnte ich gewinnen, dann habe ich es gewonnen, die Kölner Haie-Tickets, den Kölner Haie-Puck, das Kölner Haie-Trikot. Aber an welchem Punkt hat das so diese Vorahnung? Nee, während ich drehe, habe ich gedacht, ja, das wäre schon lustig, wenn ich jetzt gewinne. Und irgendwie habe ich so ein sehr manifestierter Gedanke aber schon, wo ich mir das vorstelle und dann passiert es genauso. Aber du hast aber auch, aber wir müssen jetzt natürlich den wissenschaftlichen Falsifizierbarkeitstest machen, du hast manchmal auch die Situation, dass du am Rad drehst und denkst, na, das wird nix. Ja. Ja, okay, also das Gegenbeispiel hast du auch, dass du drehst und sagst, na, das wird nix. Es ist so ein sehr spezieller Gedanke, wo man sich so plastisch vor Augen führen kann. Man ist so da und dann setzt es ein. Und das in diesem State of Mind wollte ich dann, reverse engineered, bei dem Haus auch. Also je mehr ich mich mit einer zukünftigen Familie in diesem Haus sehe.
Dir ist schon klar, dass wenn du das jetzt hier im Podcast sagst, alle anderen Teilnehmer auch anfangen, ganz intensiv daran zu denken und zu manifestieren.
Also ich glaube, du gräbst dir das zweite Loch gerade wieder.
Dann sind wir alle in dem Haus.
Okay, ja.
Durch einen Zufall haben mehrere Lose gewonnen.
Nee, genau. Aber jetzt haben die nämlich angefangen, dieses Haus zu promoten. Mit einer Pomo-Familie, die da im Garten sitzt, die da in meinem Garten sitzt und drillt. Mit so, die haben das auch schon so eingerichtet, mit so einem Love-Kissen und so. Die greifen aber nicht zum Gewinn, die würdest du nicht mitgewinnen. Hoffentlich nicht. Okay. Und dann war da neulich ein Typ auf meinem Dach. Und das alles... Ich verstehe schon, du redest schon so, als hättest du es, um das zu manifestieren. Und dieses Gewinnspiel verliert mich gerade extrem und ich hätte vielleicht nochmal neue Lose gekauft, bin ich ehrlich, wenn dann nicht diese Familie in meinem Garten gewesen wäre, an meinem Grill und dieser Typ auf dem Dach. Weil dann denke ich mir, ihr macht es einem schwierig, euch vorzustellen, dass man da wohnt. Und ich glaube dieses ... Also so eine Art Anti-Manifestationsstrategie, dass die deine Fantasie behindert. Ja, unabhängig von dieser ganzen Manifestation und dass ich mich da nicht mehr in dem Haus sehe, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das eher dazu führt, dass Leute da nicht mitmachen. weil ich glaube, zu Gewinnspielen zählt auch immer, sich das vorzustellen, der Spaß.
Wir hatten jetzt Backstage-Rubbellose. Natürlich stellt man sich beim Rubbellosen-Rubbeln vor den Gewinn vor und es ist Teil des Spasses. Wenn du direkt reingehst mit, ähm, ja, ich werde wahrscheinlich eh nichts gewinnen. Ist das natürlich nicht die gängige Strategie, das heißt, ja haben ja drei Lose, ich werde eh nichts gewinnen. Ja, eben, das macht ja gar keinen Sinn, das macht ja gar keinen Spaß. Aber wenn da fünf gutaussehende Models im Garten sitzen, kannst du dich nicht mehr rein identifizieren, als wenn da jetzt leere Gartenstühle stünden. Ja. Die Leute blockieren deine Fantasie, dass du, du kannst nicht jetzt Photoshop-mässig den Kopf ausschneiden, deinen Kopf da drauf. Die beleben ja das Haus. Ja? Die beleben das Haus. Und es sieht so aus, als wärst du Gast in einem Haus. Ach so, okay, du kannst die dir nicht weg vorstellen. Du kannst dich nicht vorstellen, ah, ich bin der Typ. Doch, doch, mir fällt das alles nur schwerer. Okay. Natürlich. Und dann ist da ein Typ auf dem Dach und ich denke mir, was macht der auf unserem Dach? Wund er auf unserem Dach. Das heisst aber, selbst wer da gewinnen würde, zumindest die Models, der Fotograf, die alle wissen ja, wo das Haus ist. Das heisst, es gibt ja schon mal über den Schnitt die viele Leute, die wissen, wo dein Haus ist. Ist das ein Problem? Ja, ich finde das nicht schön. Es führt dazu, dass ich jetzt keine Lose mehr gekauft habe. Vielleicht auch gut. Oder ist es alles eine Strategie? Also es ist am 4. November Disclaimer, wir nehmen gerade davor auf, aber am 4. November ist die Auslosung. Okay, das heisst, aber ist das jetzt vielleicht von dir nur eine Strategie, dass du Leute davon abhalten willst, noch weitere Lose zu kaufen, weil du vielleicht im Geheimen ... Mein Mouth is sealed. Ja, aber dein Kopf sagt ja, dass du ganz viele gekauft hast und vielleicht auch versucht hast, den Notar zu bestechen. Meine Mimik ist sehr transparent, but my mouth is sealed. Du musst halt nur an den Notar irgendwie rankommen. Notar. Du musst irgendwie an den Notar ran. Aber Notar ist auch ein geiler Job. Also vor allem ich glaube, es gibt zwei Notare. Es gibt dann irgendwie so die ernsten Notare, die dann so Erb Nachlass und sowas verwalten. Und dann gibt es halt so die Fun-Notare, die sitzen bei Schlag den Raab, die sitzen bei Gewinnspielen rum. Ja, Fun-Fight. Das sind auch eher so Entertainer, Showman Typen. Ja, ich hatte einmal in meinem Leben was mit einem Notar zu tun. Und das war der, der bei DSDS damals dabei war, bei der, am Ende, bei der Verkündigung. Und das hat dir der unaufgefordert erzählt, oder woher weisst du das? Der wurde mir empfohlen, durch einen Bekannten wurde der mir empfohlen. Von, von, von, jetzt weiss ich nicht, wie der heisst, Klafs, der Typ. Alexander Klafs. Alexander Klafs, sehr guter Glück. Ja, sehr gut. Danke. Das wurde, der wurde mir empfohlen und dann habe ich den genommen und ich wollte den erst nicht haben, weil ich dachte, er ist so ein Fun-Notar. Ich glaube aber, das ist nicht, ich glaube Notare haben auch Fun-Jobs. Ich glaube, es gibt zwei ganz klare Trennungen. Ich glaube, am jährlichen Notarkongress gibt es zwei Tische, der eine wirklich mit so einem Clown, der aus so einer Box rauskommt, Fontäne, Kindertisch, alle besoffen und dann wirklich so Succession-mässig, superreich, alles super edel, wo dann dieser kleine Vogel, Fettvogel gegessen wird und so. Super krass, das sind dann so die, das sind dann die Kassnotar. Entschuldigung, ich bin eine Taube. Die werden noch in Fett ertränkt, glaube ich, oder? Ja, gut. Diese Maushauben. Ja, das macht sich so ein Fettvogel. Wenn du in Fett stirbst, bist du ein Fettvogel. Sorry, Entschuldigung, aber du bist nicht Schicksal deines, hierher über dein Schicksal. Muss man einfach sagen. Und die werden gegessen mit so einer Haube über dem Kopf. Mit so einer Haube, ja, damit man das nicht so sieht. Also serviert. Ja, aber ist, glaube ich, auch verboten und deswegen auch was ganz Besonderes. Vielleicht werden wir die Fettammer mal selber ammern. Mal sich schön rein ammern, to go. Aber dürfen wir nicht davon erzählen. Dürfen wir nicht davon erzählen, wir dürfen nicht dabei gesehen werden. Die letzten Tage hier in Hamburg fand ich sehr verstörend. Hier ist sehr viel Schlimmes passiert. Deswegen verstehe ich da auch, dass du raus willst hier. Weg. Hamburg ist ein hartes Pflaster also wirklich erster tag laufe ich um die ecke liegt da irgendwie ein typ am boden nach so einer art messerangriff sah es aus ein es war ein polizist sogar dann ein anderer polizist beugte sich darüber das war schlimm dann standen leute in der reihe haben zuge, ganz viele Streifenwagen an, ich verstört rumgelaufen. Dann am nächsten Tag sagt ein Freund von mir, ey, hier ist gerade vor meiner Wohnung jemand erschossen worden. Hier in Hamburg. Einfach so? Da wurde einfach jemand erschossen, man weiss nicht warum. Der wurde erschossen. Krass. Das ist so, und das waren die letzten Tage in Hamburg. Wirklich, ich laufe hier jetzt nur noch mit. Meine Perle. Ich, ich mache, ich habe keine Kopfhörer mehr. Du brauchst dieses Haus, ne? Du willst dieses fucking Haus. Ich will weg, weg. Raus. Ja, Problem bei diesem Haus ist, alle wissen, alle Auftragsmörder potenziell wissen, wo das ist. Nein, aber die können ja raus, wenn nur es ist. Deswegen willst du ja nicht in so einem Haus leben. Ja, ja, ja. Ja, aber das, diese, dieses fand ich sehr verstörend also hamburg ist mir zu krass krass dass man einfach jetzt einfach jemanden erschießt das ist so man stellt sich das so in den usa oder so vor aber in deutschland dass da jemand aber hat er dann die pistole einfach dabei oder einfach so ein halfter oder so er ist nach hause gekommen es kam zu einem streit ja was bei mir sofort sagt gut Auftragsmord war es schon mal nicht. Beim Auftragsmord entbricht kein Streit. Ein Schuss ging auch ins Bein, da habe ich gedacht, okay, Bein, Auftragsmord passt auch nicht zusammen. Da sehe ich direkt Handgemenge. Naja, und dann der besagte Freund hat dann ein Bildgeschickt von seiner Wohnungstür, weil er musste dann die ganze Nacht im Café gegenüber verbringen, weil Polizeispurensicherung, Tatortreiniger halt in seinem Haus waren. Und dann waren wohl irgendwelche Schmauchspuren an seiner Tür. Und dann kam er zurück zu seiner Wohnungstür, wo du dich eh schon nicht mehr sicher fühlst, weil davor jemand erschossen wurde im Hausflur und es war einfach ein grosses Loch in seiner Tür.
Und das hat die Polizei herausgeschnitten.
Die nehmen ein Türstück mit.
Die haben dem Türstück mitgenommen.
Da war nämlich, und da drüber
klebt so ein Zettel mit so einer kleinen Nummer, so einer Beweisnummer.
Und dann darunter ist ein grosses,
aber so ein unförmiges Loch
ausgeschnitten worden.
Da ist jetzt einfach ein Loch in der Tür. Da kann man einfach rein. Ja, und was sichert man denn das Loch in der Tür? Ja, vor allem das ist ja ein Kriminalitätsdomino-Effekt. Weil jetzt da natürlich wieder Leute einbrechen und dann muss da wieder Spuren gesichert werden. Und Stück für Stück wie Domino Day fällt ganz Hamburg, weil die das immer weiter treiben. In Lauffeuer Hamburg ist irgendwie zu fallen. Hamburg fällt und der erste Dominostein wurde umgeworfen. Aber das ist ganz komisch. Ich bin ja durchaus wild manchmal in der Wohnung. Ich habe einen Stoffball, ich habe ein Schwert, ich werfe Sachen durch die Gegend Flumi, Klötze, was auch immer, alles Mögliche. Ich habe lange mit dir bei Vergutelarbeit Originals gearbeitet im Raum. Ich bin ein sportlicher Typ. Alles so Sportarten im Umkreis von zwei Metern mag ich immer gerne. Und oft war es auch so, dass ich wirklich teilweise so ein Stück Holz auch einfach recht fest gegen das Fenster geworfen habe und ich mir immer dachte, wie schrecklich wäre es, wenn mal ein Fenster kaputt gehen würde, wenn du wirklich, weil ich würde ja nichts machen, ich würde ja nicht um halb elf Uhr nachts jetzt irgendwie Karglas anrufen oder so. Karglas repariert, Karglas tausend aus. Sondern ich würde dann einfach unterm Sterben... Karglas hat aber immer noch keinen Termin für mich. Und mein Steinschlag bleibt weiter unbehandelt. Und dann würde ich einfach liegen da mit den Scherben und liegt man da einfach dann. Und dann ist es ganz kalt und dann wickelt man sich ein und Schlafsack. Ich habe mir immer gedacht, was macht man dann mit dieser Tür? Weil die Tür mit einem Loch verfehlt den Zweck. Und die Tür ist ein recht essentieller Part einer Wohnung. War das Loch denn so gross, dass man sich da hätte durchdrücken können? Ja, man kann den Arm durchstecken und die Klinke betätigen. Na, aber dann kann man zumindest Alufolie nochmal dahinterinter sparen. Alufolie? Stimmt, sausicher. Da passiert gar nichts. Zwei, drei Schichten und es ist schon schwer da durchzukommen. Allein dieses Gefühl, wenn man so die Alufolie... Ich liebe das. Wirklich? Wirklich? Ich frag das gar nicht. Ich finde das so, wirklich so deine Hand, so dich drei, vier Schichten Alufolie durchzudrücken. Ja, finde ich nicht schlimm. Ah, nee, das finde ich schlimm. Warum, weil das schneiden könnte? Ab wie vielen Schichten Alufolie hat man ernsthaft Probleme durchzukommen? Zwanzig. Zwanzig? Ja, kriegen wir noch hin in eine Rolle, oder? Ich denke nur daran, weil ich habe früher im Kunst und ja, Boxen, durchboxen. Du könntest dich vor allem nicht festkleben, so gut, dass du nicht einfach. Also du glaubst, die Schwachstelle ist eher der Klebbahn. Ich glaube, Alufolie ist kompletter Holzweg.
Was wäre dann der ...
Du meinst Holz wäre ein besserer Weg.
Aber ich denke nur daran, weil ich im Kunstunterricht
hatte ich auch mal ein Bild gemalt
und da war ein Teil sehr hässlich
und dann habe ich den einfach ausgeschnitten
aus dem Bild und dahinter
Alufolie geklebt und das dann so abgegeben.
Ist das deine Lösung für alles eigentlich, Alufolie? Warum nicht? Also ich meine, es ist ein Allzweckbereich so und ich habe damals im Kochunterricht, hat unsere Kochlehrerin gesagt, benutzt nicht zu viel Alufolie, denn um das herzustellen wird sehr viel Energie gebraucht. Und seitdem habe ich immer Respekt vor Alufolie, weil ich mir denke, holy shit. Was steckt da alles drin? Ich stelle mir so eine riesige, so ein komplettes Kernkraftwerk vor, wo wirklich dann einfach so komplett konzentriert. Ganz viel Rauch. Und dann am Ende kommt so ganz wenig. Ja genau, so eine ganz dünne Schicht. Ganz langsam. Und dann kommen so Wagenladungen, Kohle und Ressourcen und Schweine werden alle rein in diesen Reaktor. Ganz Menschen, ganz viele Menschen, die so Kohle reinschäffen, diese riesige... Ja, teilweise Menschen müssen geopfert werden, den Leuten wird das Herz rausgerissen, alles geht in diesen Reaktor rein. Ich stelle mir Orks vor, ich weiß nicht warum. Ja, Orks arbeiten mit so Metallhelmen, Peitschen, Peitschenhiebel überall und dann unten so ganz leicht so ein Stück Alufolie. Hier, bei Toppitz. Wir kümmern uns um die Alufolie. Dann kommt so ganz langsam so ein bisschen Alufolie raus. Toppitz, Aussengeschmack, Innen. Orks. Orks. Ja, deswegen habe ich wirklich immer Respekt vor Alufolie. Musstest du, dass du bei Alufolie außen Löcher reindrücken kannst? Um die Rolle zu fixieren? Fixierst du die Rolle? Habe ich mal gelesen, habe ich nie gemacht. Hatte nie die Zeit in meinem Leben. Die Zeit in deinem Leben? Nee, nee, nee, war nicht meine Zeit. Okay, die Zeit ist die Ressource, die zu knapp wurde. Wobei, ich gestehe jetzt hier an der Stelle eine ziemlich grosse Alufolie-Verschwendung, denn, gut, das gebe ich jetzt zu und es ist ein bisschen peinlich, aber auch wenn ich schon fortgestrittenen Alters bin, ich habe keine Muffin-Form. So, wenn ich mal Muffins machen will. Wie oft machst du Muffins? Lächerlich oft. Also immer wenn es sich einen Anlass bietet, dann sage ich. Muffins ist dann dein Go-To-Rezept? Ja. Selber Muffins oder so eine Backmischung? Schokomuffins mit Kirschen. So eine Backmischung. Schokomuffins mit einer Tafel Schokolade so zerstückelt, die dann rein in den Mixer und dann schön noch mit Kirschen.
Herrlich, Kirsch, Schokolade, Schokostückchen, fantastisch. Und dann nehme ich so ein Glas, dreh das um, drück von oben so Alufolie drauf, drei Schichten, um eine Muffinform zu haben. Dafür mussten viel zu viele Ends sterben. Ja, ich weiss, ich weiss. Hat aber auch den Vorteil, dass du danach so das einfach runterziehen kannst, dann hast du ein Muffin da stehen. Ich verstehe es nicht richtig. Ich mache eine ich mache eine muffinform aus alufolie ich nehme ein glas dreh es um und drück oben drüber vor mich um die form zu geben genau das glas kommt dann weg das glas kommt dann weg das schmeiße ich weg genau und dann habe ich muffinform und dann kann man das tatsächlich ganz gut machen und ich sag mal mal so, schlecht sind die Muffins nicht.
Die sind ein bisschen grösser als normale Muffins. Ich treffe es auf, dass du eine
Muffinform
Du machst jetzt eine Sündenliste, um die
gegen mich zu verwenden eines Tages.
Ich schenk dir das. Was ein geiles Geschenk.
Schnell vor, du kriegst bald eine Muffinform
von mir zu Weihnachten, whatever.
Das ist doch kein schlechtes Geschenk. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Jetzt bin ich natürlich im Zugzwang, dir ein Geschenk zu schenken. Nee, brauchst du nicht. Aber du magst ja diese Dan-Brown-Romane so gern. Das weiss ich ja, von daher weiss ich schon, was ich dir dieses Jahr schenke. Okay, nee, pass auf, ich muss dir auch diese Muffinform nicht schenken vor mir schenken. So, das ist doch mal eine gute Strategie.
Dan fucking Brown.
Dich erpressen und dann nimmst du dein Geschenk zurück.
Ich habe jetzt wieder Da Vinci Code geschaut, ganz fantastischer Film.
Ich mag das irgendwie so zu Weihnachten.
Der nimmt sich so ernst der Film, ist so geil.
Der nimmt sich so ernst und es ist so bescheuert.
Ich liebe diese Szene, wo ganz am Anfang Tom Hanks seine Vorlesung gibt und gezeigt wird, der Typ kennt sich gut mit Symbolen aus. Und dann ist es, und dann wirklich, du hast diese, diese, diese. Und er steht vom Klo und du hast links so ein Kleid und rechts so ein Mann. Ja, das Kleid ist ein Zeichen der Weiblichkeit, schon immer gewesen bei den okkulten Germanen. Und dann geht er rein, ich stehe meine Achillette. Und du weißt, okay, der hat... He got it, he's got it! Und er macht eine Vorlesung mit dem unrealistischsten Unipublikum, das es gibt. Ich glaube, die unrealistischsten Studenten, die ich je in meinem Leben gesehen habe, die wirklich... Und dann zeigt er so ein Dreizack und dann sagt er, was verbinden sie damit? Und die Studenten instant, Teufel, Untergang, Inferno, aus allen Räumen desumen des hörsaals kommen schlagworte extrem motivierte gruppe und dann zoomt er auf und sagt nee das ist poseidon und dann die die studenten so das kann nicht sein das kann nicht für die und dann zeigt er so in dessunlich. Und dann zeigt er so ein Hakenkreuz und alle so Terror, Menschenverachtung, sofort, ins Sinn. Und dann zoomt er auf und das ist so ein buddhistisches Symbol. Und alle so. Und das ist so herrlich bescheuert. Diese Leute, die ja. Unisettings immer weird im Film. Vor allem, das sind ja Studenten von Symbolik oder was, die haben ja auch schon mal ein Buch gelesen, das ist ja nicht, die sind ja nicht komplett dumm wie der Zuschauer, trotzdem, die müssen ja natürlich als Stand-in fungieren. Ja, ich liebe, Uniszenen in Filmen sind immer so geil, aber die sind ja nie im dritten Akt oder zweiten Akt, die sind immer der erste Teil. Und auch bei Social Network diese Klischee-Szene, wir lieben Aaron Sorkin, aber diese Klischee-Szene, wie Mark Zuckerberg dann irgendwie so zu spät kommt oder ich weiss gar nicht mehr, oder früher geht und dann so, ah, Mark Zuckerberg, verstehen Sie es nicht? Und er da so im Weggehen. Geben Sie schon auf, Zuckerberg, Sie geben auch auf. Und er im Zurückgehen dann noch so die richtige Antwort murmelt und dann die Tür geht zu und er sagt dann zu den anderen Studenten, ja das war richtig, dieser geschlagene Professor. Ich liebe auch diese, es ist so fucking auch so uncool, weil alle anderen wissen das nicht. Ja, weil so die Vorstellung für Leute, die jetzt nicht so intellektuell sind, weil ich glaube gerade so Da Vinci Code, das ist ja interessant für Leute, die sich mit sowas nie beschäftigen und halt so Mona Lisa und so raunen, wie man denen eine Vorstellung des Unilebens gibt und auch so was dieser Professor einfach für eine Macht hat und einfach so, ja, das Zeichen für Weiblichkeit. Also wieder so gut, dann kommen sie zu diesem. Bahnbrechendste, was sie je gehört hat. Dann kommen sie zu Ian McKellen. Ist das Ian McKellen oder ist das einer, der so aussieht wie Ian McKellen? Das ist Ian McKellen. Ja, genau. Sir Ian McKellen. So, und dann kommen sie zu dem und da gucken sie sich ja dann diese, das letzte Abendmahl an und so. Ja. Diese jahrtausende alten Bilder. Ja. Und dann lösen sie aber alle Geheimnisse von Da Vinci in dieser Nacht. Ja. Das ist so geil. Wirklich diese jahrhunderte alten Geheimnisse in diesen Bildern werden alle gecrackt in dieser einen Nacht, während sie von dem Mönch gejagt werden. Es ist so fantastisch, es ist so gut. Sieh das, vor dem hatte ich richtig Angst. Den mache ich richtig gern. Ach ja, toll, toller Film. Ja, okay, Dan Brown it is. Oder, hast du die nicht verschlungen? Ich dachte, du sagst mal, die verschlinge ich. Früher als Kind habe ich die geliehen. Dan Brown, die verschlinge ich. Also ich muss sagen, Illuminati hat mich sehr beeindruckt als Kind. Habe ich an der Ostsee gelesen, damals am Strand. Habe ich im Sand. Aber du warst eigentlich im Vatikan. Illuminati, genau, gelesen. Weihrauch in der Nase. Mochte das sehr Konklave., kommt bald der Film raus. Ach, da gibt es noch einen Teil? Ähm, nee, jetzt habe ich keinen Dan Brown Film, aber das Konklave kommt bald in den Film und finde ich geil. Alles, was Verschwörung mit Vatikan zu tun hat und so, finde ich fantastisch. Ist immer gut, ist immer gut, so alte Katakomben und dann so Linien und dann darunter ist irgendwas und so, toll. Ich glaube, Dan Brown privat unangenehm. Ja? Mit dem will ich nicht durch die Stadt laufen. Nee. Stell ich mir sehr anstrengend vor. Also wenn es heisst, das perfekte Promi-Dinner, eingeladen Stefan Tietze und Dan Brown. Würdest du sagen? Würdest du absagen oder Krankheit vortäuschen oder? Nee, ich würde sagen, okay gut, wenn die Gage, du kennst mich, wenn die Gage stimmt, bin ich dabei. Okay, und dann geht die Tür auf und sagt, Leute, habt ihr Lust auf die Dan Brownies? Sie sind noch warm. Wusstet ihr, dass der Vatikan 1738 ganz viele Geheimnisse rund um die Tempelritter verschollen lassen ist?
Wusstet ihr, dass der heilige Gral ursprünglich eigentlich eine Metapher war?
Für die Weiblichkeit?
Für die Weiblichkeit? Für die Weiblichkeit.
Ja, wir haben alle ihre Bücher ge-
Was sagt ihr da? Ich dachte, das wäre einfach ein Trinkbecher. Ne, eben nicht. Ja, haben wir besprochen. Ne, ich stell mir dir anders vor, ich stell mir dir vor so, ah, die Lampe, sie ist schief, sie zeigt nach Norden, ah, im Norden, der Nordstern, der steht für den Weg, das Ziel, ah, Hans Zimmer, ich mach Hans Zimmer noch ein bisschen lang, ich mach Hans Zimmer graduell lauter, ah, ich traf nach Norden, ah, und er rennt heraus, und er sagt, der Baum, zeig nach rechts, ah, es war alles, die Lösung war die ganze Zeit in mir, ich bin der Nachfahre, Jesu. Und dann spielt sich der Vordergrund am Ende. Und währenddessen, also die Bohnen sind noch nicht ganz durch. Das Ende ergibt gar keinen Sinn, aber irgendwie die Musik ist so krass. Schaut euch diesen Film an, wenn ihr den nicht kennt. Ich habe tatsächlich mal so eine Doku gesehen, die Dan Brown debunked hat. Und das hatte ich nicht gebraucht. Warum nimmst du den Leuten den Spaßweg? Weil dann gibt es ja auch die Szene, wo irgendwie dann in Venedig oder so dann irgendeine Statue und der Vogel zeigt in irgendeine Richtung. Und dann haben die mal mit der Ortsverwaltung. Ja, so wie du, so Filmfehlerforum-Guys, der zeigt gar nicht nach Norden. Und dann haben die mal mit der Ortsverwaltung gesprochen, mit diesem Vogel auf dieser Statue und haben die gefragt, also ist da was dran, wie wurde die installiert und meinte er, da kommt einmal im Jahr, kommt jemand, schraubt die ab, macht die sauber und schraubt die wieder drauf und dann guckt die in eine andere Richtung. So ist die Welt, so ist die Welt und dann will ich doch lieber in der Dan Brown-Welt leben. Absolut, so das ist ja die Ausflucht. Ich will doch lieber in einer Welt leben, wo Dinge Bedeutung haben, als einfach, ja, da kommt halt irgendein Stadtmitarbeiter, macht die Taube sauber, reibt sich die Taube, dann wird die einfach draufgeschraubt. Haben Sie das ja sonst noch Fragen, Sie Witzbold. Hat Jesus Nachfahren? Nein. Ja, okay. Keine, von dem wir wissen. Nein, Das ist nachgewiesen, das ist erforscht, das ist gut erforscht. von dem wir wissen. Nein, ist nachgewiesen. Ist erforscht, ist gut erforscht.
Keiner von dem wir wissen. Könnten ja noch Geheimnisse liegen im Wartikel.
Haben Sie noch Fragen, noch Fragen.
Diese Linien auf dem Boden, zeigen die zu den Nachfahren von Jesus?
Nein, nein, das ist natürlich Zufall.
Da kam gestern so ein Wagen von der Stadt und hat hier sauber gemacht, der hat die Lieselin hinterlassen. Okay. Diese Musik sind vier Akkorde, das ist nichts Besonderes. Okay, ich mach's aus. Dieses Kind kann das schreiben. Okay, ich mach's aus. Ja, das ist Venedig, ne? Das ist das Leben. Tod in Venedig. Nee, das ist das Leben. Das ist Venedig. Du warst ja auch enttäuscht von Venedig, ne? Da hat ja eigentlich deine Dan Brown-Skepsis schon angefangen, so ein bisschen, ne? Also diese herrlichen europäischen, aber Dan Brown ist Engländer oder Amerikaner, oder ist es noch aus der amerikanischen Sicht eh noch mal Europa, so alte Geschichte und verborgene Dinge und Kreuzzug. Amerikanischer Autor, ja, das merkt man ein bisschen. Na ja. Daniel, Daniel Brownisst er eigentlich. Da musst du dich doch jetzt nicht draufhauen. Daniel Browning heisst er eigentlich. Wirklich? Ich finde geil, dass sein Nachname auch einen Spitznamen hat. Daniel Brown ist ein US-amerikanischer Thriller-Autor. Also, der unterrichtete Englisch, bevor er sich ganz natürlich kein Schriftsteller widmete, als ältestes von drei Kindern des Mathematikprofessors an der an der Philip X Academy und Autors eines Mathematik-Schullehrbuchs und der bekannten Kirchenmusikerin wuchs er so die Werbung in den Klappentexten seiner Bücher in einem Umfeld auf, in dem Wissenschaft und Religion keine Gegensätze darstellten. Diese können jetzt und seien auch den weltweiten Erfolgs auch das Unab. Des Weiteren ist er ein Nachfahre Jesu Christi. Ach ja, stell dir vor, es würde rauskommen, irgendjemand, stell dir vor, es würde rauskommen, Jürgen Trittin ist Nachfahre Jesu. Würde mich nicht wundern. Würde das wirklich viel ändern? Also würde das für Leute wirklich was rumdrehen? Oder wäre es egal? Es kommt raus, Olaf Scholz ist der Nachfahre von Judas. Nee, sagen wir wirklich von Jesu Christi. Ja. Ich glaube, es wird einen massiven Einfluss nehmen auf seine öffentliche Wahrnehmung. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, da werden nochmal zwei, drei Prozentpunkte drin auf jeden Fall. Zwei, drei Prozentpunkte? Ja, ja, ja, ja. Naja, es gibt ja Leute, die darauf warten, für die sagen, für die heißt es, die Rückkehr Jesu ist wichtig und der kommt nochmal irgendwann zurück, der ist nicht komplett raus, der ist
in den Himmel gefahren und sagt dann
ja, ist aber so
2000 Jahre und
dann komme ich wieder, sowas?
Warum nicht
am Mittwoch?
Naja, schon machen wir schon
2000 Jahre erstmal.
Ich warte noch ein paar Jahre, ich warte noch ein paar Jahre. Wir sind noch nicht bereit. Vielleicht wenn Hans Zimmer stirbt. Ich finde es so gut, dass wir uns immer so Filme reinnerden, die wir beiden gut kennen und mögen, aber da draußen vielleicht nicht. Doch, doch, doch, ich glaube da draußen gibt es ganz viele der Vinci- Code Fans. Es ist ein Klassiker. Ich glaube, das meiste, was die Leute über Kirche wissen, kommt einfach von Dan Browning. Daniel Browning. Welchen Film findest du besser? Sakrileg oder Filmmenati? Nein, Da Vinci Code. Der andere ist Trash. Der andere ist Trash. Den habe ich nur einmal gesehen, aber werde ich es vielleicht nochmal angucken. Auch Ron Howard? Nee, nee, nee. Ich brauche neue Weihnachtsrituale und ich glaube, Dan Brown ist jetzt Teil davon. Okay, cool. Und ich will dieses Jahr unbedingt nochmal Schlittschuh laufen. Ja, ich bin gestern hier in Hamburg an einem Gebäude vorbeigekommen, auf dem Dach ist eine Schlittschuh. Okay, ich habe genug Filme von Jackass gesehen, um zu wissen, dass das eine schlechte Idee ist. Aber in Dänemark gibt es so eine Müllverbrennungsanlage und das Dach ist eine Skipiste. Und seitdem denke ich mir, okay, alles ist möglich, alles ist wundervoll, wir denken Städte falsch, wenn eine Müllverbrennungsanlage, die muss ja extrem gekühlt werden auch, bla bla bla bla. Warum muss sie gekühlt werden, die ist so heiß. Weiss ich nicht genau. Jedenfalls ist es auf einer Art, das Dach war es dann naheliegend und da hatte der Architekt eine ganz tolle Idee und es ist eine Skipiste. Ist das nicht die typische Idee, da wo es heiß ist, eine Skipiste hinzubauen? Nee. Okay, gut. Du hast mich überzeugt. Ich kann dir jetzt leider nicht die genauen Gründe nennen, sei es irgendwie die aufwendige Kühlung, die eine Müllverbrennungsanlage braucht, um nicht zu warm, sie zu überhitzen, weil die noch nie in der Stadt ist. Und die muss man einfach nur zwei Stufen weiter aufdrehen und dann kann man auch Skifahren direkt. Genau, oder die nutzen die Energie, um zu kühlen. Spannend, ich hätte jetzt bei Dänemark gar nicht an so eine Skifahrerkultur gedacht, ehrlich gesagt. Die fahren sehr, sehr gerne Ski, haben aber gar keine Berge. Und das ist ja doppelt effizient und nachhaltig, weil sie dann nicht reisen müssen, sondern einfach in Kopenhagen dieses Dach runterfahren können. Also alles ganz, ganz toll und der Architekt denkt ganz toll, der hat auch jetzt irgendwie das nächste World Trade Center Turm gebaut und sowas. Der ist mutig, sehr mutig. Der ist jedenfalls starker Geist und ich denke mir, okay, Skipiste auf einer Müllverbrennungsanlage ist ja nur Schritt eins. Ich denke an Bowling Bahn auf einer Müllverbrennungsanlage. Ich denke an eine ... Also du lässt deine Kreativität, Ich denke anreibe. Ich denke an Lasertag. Ja, zum Beispiel... Auf einer Müllverbrennungsanlage. Okay, ja, ja, ja. Ich denke an, wir spielen Darts. Ja, zum Beispiel auf... Mir fällt es ein, ich bin kein Architekturgenie. Das ist auch nicht ein. Okay, ja. So eine Müllverbrennungsanlage. Ich meine, wie viele Flächen sind versiegelt mit Müllverbrennungsanlagen, wo man noch so viel drauf machen könnte? Überall stehen die rum, denke ich mir. Ja, furchtbar. Und wir nutzen die nicht richtig aus. Ich mache da einen grossen Bogen drum. Warum denn eigentlich? Ich auch. Warum nicht einfach drüber gelaufen? Und dann die genialste Idee aller Zeiten war, da kommt halt ab und zu mal so ein bisschen Qualm oben raus. Und sein Plan war, wie so ein Ring entstehen zu lassen, wie so ein Oppa, der eine Pfeife braucht. Und dann so. Dann hat er einen riesigen Mund gebaut, einfach der so. Dann kommt so ein Ring. Und das findest du eine gute Idee? Alles daran finde ich perfekt. Okay. Weil das zeigt mir doch, wir können alles anders denken. Ich finde aber gut, dass da manchmal Qualm rauskommt, ne? Also so eine Müllverbrennung. Immer wenn irgendjemand so ein Stück Plastik oder irgendwie sowas reingebaut, so ein Reifen, dann einfach müll. Meine Idee wäre eher künstlerisch, ich würde sagen, dann schreit der Schornstein. Ah, so als würde die Erde schreien. Ja, aber wenn Müll verbrannt wird, ist das nicht gut? Mitten in Köln, also ich habe mich jetzt beworben, weil die haben Ideen gesucht für die Müllverbrennungsanlagen in Köln. Ja, die brauchen Trinkideen. Und ich habe jetzt diese Schrei-Idee eingereicht. Und ich finde die Forschung toll. Mitten in Köln hast du immer diese Anlage und immer wenn was Grases verbrannt wird, was sehr viel umweltschädigend ist, kommt so ein AAAAAAAA! Ja, das finde ich ganz gut. Also meine Hegelbücher sind gerade auf dem Weg zur Müllverbrennungsanlage und ich glaube, wir kriegen alle mit, wenn wir die Lauscher mal aufsperren, wann die alle reingeworfen werden ins Feuer. Ah, Hegel! Das waren sie, das waren sie, jetzt sind sie weg. Ja, aber ich bin jetzt raus aus Köln, ich bin raus aus meiner Wohnung, war wirklich ein Pflaster abreissen, war auch schmerzhaft, ich habe ganz viele alte Dinge zurückgelassen. Was wirst du am meisten an Köln vermissen? Ähm. Gut, du bist jetzt eh man dich hinsetzt. Ja, ich lebe in Azzarot, ich bin Cosmopolit, ich lebe im Internet. Aber ich habe mir mal tatsächlich ein E-Piano geholt. Das wirst du am meisten an Köln vermissen, das E-Piano bei dir im Zimmer. Ich werde die Vorstellung vermissen, dass ich eines Tages nochmal E-Piano spiele.
Okay.
Diese Vorstellung werde ich vermissen, weil diesen Traum habe ich mir selbst zerstört, weil man muss auch mal Ballast abwerfen, man muss Träume abwerfen, man muss falsche Vorstellungen abwerfen.
Wir hören kurz, wie er den Traum weggeworfen hat.
Brams!
Und es ist etwas schwer, weil ich habe überlegt, wie kann ich das transportieren, hin und her, was passiert da so und dann habe ich gesagt, ganzes Bad, alles Schimmel, überall im Wohnzimmer Schimmel und ab dann war das nicht mehr meine Wohnung. Und nicht mehr deine Stadt. Weil die hat anders gerochen, die Wohnung, es ist wirklich so, also normalerweise deine eigene Wohnung riechst du ja nicht, es fällt stark auf und es war wirklich ab dem Moment. Du riechst doch nicht deine Lunge. Ach, du es sagst wenn man es weiss, riecht man die Lunge ach, das ist dieser Lungengeruch, aber es war wirklich so, ab dem Moment war es nicht mehr meine Wohnung und ich war da nicht mehr zu Hause wirklich, und danach wurde das alles wieder gestrichen und alles und so und das hat man nicht mehr gesehen, aber es war wirklich einfach nicht mehr mein Zuhause das ist ganz verrückt,, wie wichtig dieser Geruch und wie wichtig das Gefühl ist. Und das eine so ein einschneidendes Erleben, das kann einfach sagen, weil ich trauere dir jetzt auch nicht hinterher, weil es irgendwie nicht mehr meine Wohnung war ab dem Moment. Jetzt hast du dich auch in Köln umziehen können. Ja, aber dann lebe ich ja immer noch in Köln. Und ich habe wirklich tatsächlich, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich einen dramatischen Abgang machen will, weil ich habe direkt gegenüber von der Kneipe gewohnt. Und die Kneipe war gar nicht so das Problem, aber ein einziger Gast dieser Kneipe war ein Problem. Das war so ein älterer, so ein klassischer, glaube ich, älterer Kölner Typ, weisser Schnurrbart, weisse schütteres Haar, Bierbauch und dann wirklich immer so, Et gött wie et gut, und dann wirklich immer mitgesungen, aber nie Text, sondern immer so, wie ich so auf dem Niveau mitgesungen die Lieder und so.
Und es war so laut, so spät, dass ich wirklich mir immer im Bett liegend vorgestellt habe, wie ich zu dem hingehe und sage, sie sind so fucking laut und schauen sie sich die ganzen Häuser hier an, die ganzen Wohnungen überall, da schlafen Babys, da schlafen Kinder und sie gehen allen auf den Sack hier, nur sie, die Musik ist kein Problem, ihre ganzen Freunde, der ganze Tisch ist alles kein Problem, nur sie, nur ihr fucking Organ, dann dachte ich mir, wenn ich jetzt ausziehe, soll ich nochmal zu dem gehen und sagen, sie haben mich jetzt sieben Jahre lang terrorisiert mit ihrer Scheisse und ich denke, dass sie einfach zu halten. Aber es ist, ich habe es nicht gemacht, ich weiß nicht, ob ich den nochmal sehe, ob ich den nochmal, weil ich hätte so gerne, dass der zumindest eine Ahnung davon hat, was er den Leuten alles antut. Der kann, vielleicht macht er weiter, vielleicht ist es ihm egal, vielleicht sagt er, ich brauche das, nach dem stressigen Tag in der Kneipe mit meinen Freunden einfach zu grönen, ich brauche das, ist ja okay. Ich will, dass er zumindest weiss, was er anrichtet. Das ist alles, was ich will. Ich finde schön, dass das Ende deines Films... ...wäre dann wie du Köln verlässt? Ja. Machst du die Wohnungstür zu, Schimmelwohnung.
Und du gehst nicht einfach los.
Nein.
Zum Bahnhof, nein, nein, du drehst dich um.
Grosse Augen, das ist eine Idee.
Du gehst zurück, da gab es doch diese Bar und diesen Typen.
Ja.
Du gehst hin, machst die Tür, schlägst die Tür zur Kneipe auf und sagst, Sie! Sehen Sie da hoch? Sehen Sie die ganzen Wohnungen? Die Familien, die Kinder, die Hoffnungen, die Sorgen. Es sind Krankenschwestern, es sind Pflegekräfte, es sind Ärzte, es sind Feuerwehrmänner und Frauen, und sie brüllen abends ihre Kölschen Lieder, Viva Colonia, oder Kölsche Jung, der Trömmelsche, der Trömmelsche Küt, Hennes der Geistburg Küt, FC Köln, Irafeld, Radatal, Nippes, Pol, Esch, Pech und Kalk nicht mehr mit mir. Ich ziehe aus und deswegen sage ich ihnen, dass sie ab jetzt ihre Klappe halten. Und dann nimmst du deine Hand und pfefferst dem einfach ins Gesicht. Nimmst du den Kölsch, seinen Gaffelkölsch und schmeißt ihn ins Gesicht.
Und er schaut mich mit grossen Augen an und antwortet nur,
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa,
Und ich drehe mich um und war nie wieder in Köln gesehen.
Der Dom, wir sehen den Dom, wir zoomen raus in der Luft, wir fliegen über die Welt.
Wir sehen, dass der Dom von oben ein Kreuz ist. Ja, und er zeigt, das Kreuz zeigt auf genau meine Wohnung, aufs E-Piano. Doch es wird abgeholt, es wird reingeworfen in den Müllcontainer, das E-ast. Wir fliegen wieder auf den Dom. Und wir fliegen in den Dom rein. Und wir sehen, hinterm Altar, im Dom, ist der Schrein der Heiligen Drei Könige. Er war die ganze Zeit da. Er war die ganze Zeit da, das, wonach du gesuchst hast. Ja, Kaspar, Melchior, Balthasar, alle drei. Moment mal, sind das Kisten? Ist das Bernstein? Moment mal, eine Türklinke aus Rheinz-Bernstein! Und die Kamera zoomt zurück. Written and directed by Daniel Browning. Daniel Browning. Score by Hans Zimmer! Hans Zimmerchen! Hans Bernstein Zimmer! Ja genau, oder so. So in etwa, ne? Also jetzt bin ich raus aus Köln. Gut, ja schön, ciao. Und das war's. Ja, bin ich schlecht, bin ich schlecht. Ich mag Hamburg auch, bin nicht ganz ehrlich, du machst da nichts falsch. Erstmal, ich mag Köln sehr. Ich habe, neulich muss ich sagen, weil in Köln, man wird schon gezwungen, abends am Kiosk, Kölsch, alt trinken Kölsch. Du musst, ne, sonst wirst du da abgestochen. Man wird abgestochen. Nee, in Köln wird man nicht abgestochen, dann kriegst du eine Backpfeife. Nee, aber ich mag Kölsch sehr gerne, man kann es gut trinken. Inzwischen liebe ich das tatsächlich ganz gerne zu trinken.
Man steht aber immer vor diesem Kühlschränken und alle um einen herum nehmen wie selbstverständlich ihre Kölschsorte.
Es gibt ja zig, es gibt ja zwanzig Kölschsorten.
Und ganz ehrlich, eh in Deutschland, Rheinlandsgebur, das sind immer nur drei Zutaten, Bier generell.
Kölsch ist jetzt diese sehr spezielle Unterart, das zu machen.
Die werden alle super gleich gemacht. Man müsste also sagen, okay, es schmeckt alles irgendwie wahrscheinlich sehr ähnlich. Aber alle sagen immer so selbstverständlich, ne, ich nehme mal Gilden, ne, ich nehme mal Schreckenskammer, ne, ich nehme mal Gaffel, ne, ich nehme mal Mühlenkölsch. So, und dann dachte ich mir, warum, wo haben die denn dieses Selbstverständnis her? Weil ich immer so, was gefällt mir heute für ein Etikett? Das war so meine Idee. Und dann habe ich gedacht, nee, komm, das geht so nicht mehr weiter. Und dann habe ich ein Kölsch-Tasting gemacht. Ah ja, also offizielles oder privat? Blind-Tasting, ganz privat. Ah ja, also du hast zu Hause alleine gesoffen. Ich habe mit einem Kumpel, der uns alles an Kölsch besorgen konnte, an Kölsch-Sorten, die wir finden konnten. Es waren glaube ich am Ende 13 Stück. War ein Notar anwesend? Es war ein Notar anwesend. Sehr anwesend sehr gut so und dann haben wir blind wurden uns die dann gebracht in gläsern da waren auch andere da wir beide haben die bekommen in gläsern deswegen muss ich aber sagen klar am kiosk trinken wir aus der flasche das ändert den geschmack weiss ich war aber nicht anders machbar an der flasche erkenne ich kenne niemand hat problem Aufbau dieses Tests. Ich erkenne einen Mühlen, doch, du hast die Frage gestellt und der Notar auch. Naja, aber deswegen, so dann habe ich, haben wir das aufgeschrieben, nummeriert, dann geguckt, Geruch, Geschmack, Farbe, was erinnert uns das, Assoziation. Ach so, ihr wart nicht blind, ihr wusstet nur nicht, was ihr trinkt. Blindtest, genau, aber in einem neutralen Glas. Hab ich. So, und da hab ich, und da war ich sehr stolz drauf, aufs Dreizehn-Sorten, meine Lieblingssorte, von der ich dachte, dass ich sie am liebsten mag, herausgeschmeckt. Mühlenkölsch. Ach, Mühlenkölsch ist mit Abstand das beste Körsch. Auf Platz zwei war ich mit Schreckenskammer, mag ich beide sehr. Dann kommt natürlich Klassiker, Reisdorf, die Sünder, ganz abgeschlagen eben früh, sehr beliebt, aber war nicht so meins, war ein bisschen bitterer Nachgeschmack. Kann ich dir eben empfehlen, macht das in euren Städten, es macht irgendwie Spaß und man hat einen lustigen Abend und da habe ich es herausgefunden. Ich trinke ja gerne Mr. Max, also diese fünf Liter, die nach Farbstoff schmecken. Es gibt drei verschiedene Farbstoffen, aber da kam tatsächlich für mich auch was zusammen. Und zwar, ich habe ja meinen Geldeimer noch in Köln und ich habe jahrelang versucht, diesen scheiß Geldeimer loszuwerden mit dem ganzen Kleingeld. Ich kriege es nicht hin, diese fucking Geldautomaten, die es bei Supermärkten gibt, da muss man das dann immer sich an der Kasse auszahlen lassen und der Höchsteinzahlwert ist zu niedrig und das ist alles furchtbar, weil ich möchte ja gerne am Ende einen Zettel haben, wo alles draufsteht, wo alle meine Münzen aufgelistet werden. Das ist mir wichtiger als das Geld. Ich will einfach nur sehen, so und so viele 120 Cent-Stücke und so und ich will das einfach haben. Und habe ich nie geschafft in Köln, deswegen habe ich den jetzt umgezogen, den Geldeimer, den kann ich aber nicht tragen, weil der viel zu schwer ist, der wiegt irgendwie dreissig Kilo oder so und deswegen habe ich das jetzt umgefüllt in die ganzen Mr. Max-Flaschen, die ich noch hatte, diese fünf Liter Plastikflaschen. Es kommt alles zusammen. Es kommt wirklich alles zusammen und die habe ich alle so halb voll gemacht und dann konnte ich die gut transportieren im Auto. Wenn du davon erst noch Booster Energy Drinks kaufst und WC enden, dann sind wir wieder 2006 angekommen. Dann sind wir wirklich wieder von 2006. Dann wäre das sozusagen unsere Zehnjahresfolge. Ja. Ja, krass, super. Ja, mal gucken. Also das ist eine Investition, die werde ich jetzt möglichst schnell auf den Kopf hauen, gemeinsam mit meinen sieben Gramm Zahngold, die ich ja auch noch habe. Also ich habe Geld, so ist es nicht, nur halt nicht in Geldform. Das Vermögen ist da, ich kann mir das leisten, ich habe jetzt Sky gekündigt, da ist auch wieder eine Menge Geld drin. Sky, wow, wow. Ich bin kein Formel-1-Fan mehr. Ich habe jetzt Sky Sport gekündigt, weil ich mir immer nur die kostenlosen Podcasts angehört und die kostenlosen Videos auf YouTube angeguckt und hatte nie Zeit, mir die Rennen live anzuschauen.
Deswegen eine Ära endet. Sky Sport gekündigt, weil ich habe mir immer nur die kostenlosen Podcasts angehört und die kostenlosen Videos auf YouTube angeguckt
und hatte nie Zeit, mir die Rennen live anzuschauen.
Deswegen eine Ära endet.
Ich bin kein
Intellektueller mehr,
Hegel ist weg, ich bin kein Musiker mehr,
E-Piano ist weg und ich bin
kein Formel-1-Fan mehr, Abo ist
weg. Vielleicht warst du auch nie
Formel-1-Fan,
Musiker und Intellektuell. Aber was bin ich denn dann? Ein Dan-Brown-Fan. Denn das ist, was uns alle verbindet. Vielleicht bin ich der Nachfahr Jesu, das weiss man nicht. Ich habe manchmal schon so das Gefühl, wenn ich so Bilder sehe, dann ich mir, Papa? Bei Jesus jetzt oder generell bei Bildern von deinem Vater? Nee, wenn ich Jesus sehe, wenn ich die Passion Christi sehe oder so, und dann sehe ich den Schauspieler von Jesus und sage, Vater? Vielleicht ist Pierre Brice dein Vater, das weiß ich nicht. Neil Gibson. Du hast wieder den Pierre-Brice-Passion gesehen. Gut, aber Pierre-Brice kann alles spielen, ne? James Bond, Jesus, den kannst du in alle Sandalen oder in Smoking stecken, der spielt dir alles weg, der Gute. Ganz ehrlich, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau, und das macht auch viel Faszination für den Mann aus, ich nicht weiss, wie man seinen Namen schreibt. Ja. Und das kenne ich bei vielen Leuten.
Bries.
Es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten zu schreiben.
B-R-I-E-C-E, sowas. Das ist ein toller Nachname. Ich mag das. Namen, die man nicht genau weiss, wie man die schreiben soll, haben für mich eine Faszination. das ist so ähnlich so es ist er sieht barack Nickelodeon, weißt du, das so sagt man gern. Barack Obama. Barack Obama. Barack Obama. Ja, na gut, wir haben noch einige Mysterien aufzuklären auf jeden Fall. Wir werden euch auf dem Laufenden halten. Aber wir hören ja auch nicht auf. Nee, nee, wir hören nicht auf und wir haben auch in dieser Folge einige geheime Hinweise versteckt. Wenn ihr denen folgt, dann könnt ihr vielleicht rausfinden, von wem Stefan Nachfahre ist. Ich sag mal, es ist einer der Aposteln, weiter gehe ich nicht. Und wir gucken mal, ob Stefan Tietzebald ein neues Haus gewinnt und dort wohnt, wo wir alle wissen, wo er wohnt. Wo dieses Haus ist. Wir wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz schöne Woche. Kommt durch die Woche, macht keinen Unsinn. Macht keinen Unsinn, gebt dem Pfand mal wieder ab, Mensch, das sammelt sich jetzt auch schon wieder an. Ja, aber schüttet Pfand voll die Tür.
Pfand schon mal, es gibt auch so Websites, wo man seinen Pfand spenden kann.
Es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten, aber weg mit dem Pfand.
Haut rein, macht's gut, wir steigen ein. Tschau, haut rein, tschau.
Bis nächste Woche.